They were trying to keep us
away from each other.
I know, what is it
in trying to keep us apart?
-Trying to keep us apart.
-Finally.
I know. They knew we were
going to become besties.
They didn't want it
to happen.
Either way, it's too much.
Yeah. It probably is.
It probably is.
Hi, I'm Gena.
I'm with Aimee Lou Wood
who plays Aimee
in Sex Education
and here are her Netflix IX.
Hello.
Obviously, last season,
we see Aimee
go through a lot.
Her storyline
was probably one
of the most gut wrenching
of that season.
Now we're entering season 3,
where is Aimee now?
What are we expecting
to see?
She's still very much
recovering and healing
from what happened during
in season 2.
You know, she grows so much
every season
and there's always--
So, in the first one,
we had
the female masturbation,
which meant so much
to so many women.
And then
in the second season,
you know,
that amazing storyline
with the boss,
which also meant so much.
And then,
I feel like this season,
it's kind of like her
getting to know her vulva
and just loving vulva.
She's just continuing
to find herself.
You become, I imagine,
a lot closer
to the character
the more you play
the character,
the more you read
about the character,
how much do you think
Aimee has changed
from the very first time
you set eyes on that script
in season 1 to season 3?
The first time
I read those scrip--
I mean, she was,
she was brilliant,
but she's just become
kind of like,
they've embraced
the kind of weirdness
and the fact that
she has such a unique way
of looking at the world.
And they've really
gone with that.
And I think back
to kind of the first time
we see Aimee is her, like,
getting out the car
with the untouchables
and she's all, like,
you know,
she's trying
to be like them,
to think of how she's--
The last time you see her
in season 3
and she's, like,
saying goodbye to Maeve,
who's her best friend,
and saying,
"Don't forget me."
And they're just so strong
and they're so together...
Yeah,
I love that friendship.
It hurts my heart.
I love them so much.
And to think about,
she's just,
she really feels
like she's gone from
-that girl to woman.
-Yeah. Absolutely. I agree.
-Totally.
-Yeah.
She'd never been single,
as well.
Like, she'd gone
from boyfriend to boyfriend,
and I think
that that's an amazing thing
that in the end of season 3,
is kind of the first time
we'll kind of see Aimee
as a single...
Yeah! You're right.
...without a boyfriend.
I never thought
that she'd be single.
'Cause, I mean,
she goes through
three boyfriends.
She has three boyfriends
in the first season.
Which is more than me
in like five years,
-kudos to Aimee.
-Yeah, exactly.
She rattles on through.
She's like
next, next, next, next,
When I spoke to Ncuti,
I asked him
who makes him laugh
the most on set?
Who makes you laugh
the most on set
or makes it hardest for you
when you're filming?
Oh! Easy.
Aimee Lou Woods is a demon.
There's no way you can be
in Aimee Lou Woods' company
and not be, like,
crying with laughter.
What do you have
to say about this, Aimee?
Is this true?
I feel exactly the same
about him.
He brings out,
and I mean from the start.
Like as soon as I saw him
and we met,
we were like, "Hello."
It was kind of like
this weird,
it was like we'd met
in a past life.
-Yeah.
-And we kind of like,
we clung to each other
quite a lot
in, like, scene--
when we were nervous
and when we filmed
all the party stuff
in season one.
But we bring out
a cheeky side in each other.
But quite chaotic.
We've got
quite chaotic energy
when we're together.
Because we are both
like that.
But we kind of,
you know, when you're around
other people,
you kind of play it
down a bit
and then,
as soon as we're together,
it unleashes.
I mean, we cannot
be left alone together.
If we have to be up early,
we can't have a dinner
the night before.
Even if we meet at seven,
we will not leave each other
until 5:00 a.m.
But we definitely
spiral off together.
We're like, okay, we're out.
We're out of here.
So would you say
that Ncuti is the person
who makes you laugh the most
on set?
Or would you say
that you and Emma
have that sort
of relationship
where it's also
very difficult
-to get you guys to finish--
-Well, this is the thing.
This is the thing.
Emma and I, I mean, we just,
I don't even know
what half of the things
that come out our mouth.
We just, as soon as
we see each other
we're going
straight into scenes,
like different characters,
we cannot speak.
There was a day
that we both forgot
what our own voices were.
We were like,
what do you speak like?
What do I speak like?
Because we're like,
we're doing
all these different accents,
we're doing all Scouse
and then we're doing, like,
we just constantly,
and we're singing
and it's just nonstop.
And people honestly walk in
and they're like, whoa.
Just quickly
on Aimee and Maeve,
because,
as we mentioned earlier,
it's such
a beautiful friendship,
but, obviously, this season,
they have their first fight,
which broke my heart.
I was like, no!
What was
your immediate reaction
to seeing the fight
when you first read
the script,
We were really nervous
about it
because it made us
actually sad.
The day
that it was happening,
we kind of went over
to Ben, our director,
and we were like,
"So, we're thinking about
is this a bit too harsh?
Do you think we could?"
We were trying
to mellow it a bit.
And he was, he was like,
"Come on. Come on, gals."
"Like do it."
And actually,
just going there
and having to say
those things to each other,
was the most,
it was so hard.
Like, I was looking at her
and she was getting so upset
and I just wanted
to give her a hug.
But what we actually got to
is that they have to really
kind of go there
with each other
and they have to be
really honest.
And we want to kind of
let people know
that their friendship
is stronger after that.
Like, they were already
best friends,
-but like, they avoided…
-Yeah.
they did avoid
kind of difficult stuff.
Like they didn't,
they avoided conflict.
And then they kind of
just have it out.
And then it actually means
that they've said
what they feel
and they've
expressed themselves.
And then they can go
from that point.
I feel like the foundations
of their friendship
are even stronger
now they've had
their first fight.
Do you ever read a line
that you have to say
or something
that's going to happen
and think, bloody hell,
I can't believe
that we're going there?
Like this, oh, my God!
Constantly. Constantly!
When I read
that opening scene,
-I was like, oh, my, God!
-Yeah!
And actually, this is
what my stepdad said.
It's actually less about
the fact it's a sex scene.
It's more about
what Aimee says.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's the stuff
that she's saying
that's like, oh, my God.
And that
is going to follow me.
I mean, honestly
like, you know,
people will always remember
that opening line...
Do you like my tits?
...you know?
And there's stuff
that I read,
and I'll think, really?
You know?
Like, there was one line
and this one was like,
I need, you know,
I need a shit.
And I think it's going to be
a sloppy one
-'cause I'm anxious.
-Yeah!
It's like, of course,
Aimee's the one
looking at her vulva
with her hand mirror.
Of course,
she makes vulva cupcakes,
Of course, she talks about
her sloppy shits.
It's just,
it's like, what have I got?
I'm always, like,
when I get the scripts,
I'm like, what have I got
this season?
What kind of...
What is going on?
Is that, you know,
there's always something
As an actor,
What has been
your most surreal experience
that you've had so far?
I actually think, currently,
I'm doing a film
with Bill Nighy.
Oh, wow.
And I did have a moment
the other day
when I was filming with him.
So, I've tried to be,
I'm trying to act
like it's normal,
but he's someone
that I have admired
since was a baba, you know?
I'm sat with him
and we're doing
the most beautiful scene
where he's doing
the most beautiful acting.
And I did have a moment
the other day where I went,
"Okay, this is, this is,"
this is surreal."
"This is like a full circle.
This is weird."
And also, I think,
probably winning the BAFTA
-was a note.
-Yeah.
I was like, "What the hell
is this all about?"
-Yeah.
-This is hilarious.
So, it's been,
I would say
the past few weeks
have probably been
the most surreal of my time
as an actor.
If you could do
literally anything else
and you'd be
really, really good at it...
Yeah?
...what would you do
as a career?
Therapist.
Really?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God!
The way you had the answer
ready on the tongue as well.
I rate that.
Because I think about it.
Sometimes, I think I'm like,
should I be,
because I would say writer,
but I also write.
I feel like that goes quite
hand in hand with acting,
but if it was
an actual career change,
yeah, I would say therapist.
Because I am fascinated
by people and by minds
and I just, yeah,
I would love to be,
I would love to be
a therapist.
Who would you
most like to meet
from another Netflix show
or movie?
I'd love to meet
Winona Ryder,
-Stranger Things.
-That's such a good one.
Because Winona, you know?
-Yeah.
-Icon.
-Absolute icon.
And also RuPaul
and Michelle Visage.
Like what, I'm basically,
there's an ongoing joke
with my friends
that I'm always just using,
like, social media
to try and campaign
to get a guest judge slot
on Drag Race.
And it's true
because I need it.
I need it.
So, I just want to be
a guest judge, that's all.
And I think you deserve.
Do you know what?
I'm going to
take that petition
straight to the boss.
Not really sure
who thought that out
-but, yeah, I would.
-Please.
I've saying
I see people on this
and I know they haven't
watched one episode
in their life
and I'm thinking,
you know, Geri Halliwell
you're great,
but you have not watched
Drag Race.